Let us now look at some examples
of sample spaces.
Sample spaces are sets.
And a set can be discrete,
finite, infinite,
continuous, and so on.
Let us start with a simpler case
in which we have a sample
space that is discrete
and finite.
The particular experiment
we will be
looking at is the following.
We take a very special die,
a tetrahedral die.
So it's a die that has four
faces numbered from 1 up 4.
We roll it once.
And then we roll it
twice [again].
Were not dealing here with two
probabilistic experiments.
We're dealing with a single
probabilistic experiment that
involves two rolls of the die
within that experiment.
What is the sample space
of that experiment?
Well, one possible
representation is the following.
We take note of the result
of the first roll.
And then we take note of the
result of the second roll.
And this gives us a
pair of numbers.
Each one of the possible pairs
of numbers corresponds to one
of the little squares
in this diagram.
For example, if the first roll
is 1 and the second is also 1,
then this particular outcome
has occurred.
If the first roll is it 2 and
the second is a 3, then this
particular outcome occurs.
If the first roll is a 3 and
then the next one is a 2, then
this particular outcome
occurs.
Notice that these two outcomes
are pretty closely related.
In both cases, we observe
a 2 and we observe a 3.
But we distinguish those two
outcomes because in those two
outcomes, the 2 and the 3 happen
in different order.
And the order in which they
appear may be a detail which
is of interest to us.
And so we make this distinction
in the sample space.
So we keep the (3, 2) and the
(2, 3) as separate outcomes.
Now this is a case of a model
in which the probabilistic
experiment can be described
in phases or stages.
We could think about rolling
the die once and then going
ahead with the second roll.
So we have two stages.
A very useful way of describing
the sample space of
experiments--
whenever we have an experiment
with several stages, either
real stages or imagined
stages.
So a very useful way of
describing it is by providing
a sequential description
in terms of a tree.
So a diagram of this kind,
we call it a tree.
You can think of this as
the root of the tree
from which you start.
And the endpoints of the
tree, we usually
call them the leaves.
So the experiment starts.
We carry out the first phase,
which in this case is the
first roll.
And we see what happens.
So maybe we get a 2
in the first roll.
And then we take note of what
happened in the second roll.
And maybe the result was a 3.
So we follow this branch here.
And we end up at this particular
leaf, which is the
leaf associated with
the outcome 2, 3.
Notice that in this tree we once
more have a distinction.
The outcome 2 followed by a 3 is
different from the outcome
3 followed by a 2, which would
correspond to this particular
place in the diagram.
In both cases, we have
16 possible outcomes.
4 times 4 makes 16.
And similarly, if you count
here, the number of leaves is
equal to 16.
The previous example involves
a sample space that was
discrete and finite.
There were only 16 possible
outcomes.
But sample spaces can
also be infinite.
And they could also be
continuous sets.
Here's an example of an
experiment that involves a
continuous sample space.
So we have a rectangular target
which is the unit square.
And you throw a dart
on that target.
And suppose that you are so
skilled that no matter what,
when you throw the
dart, it always
falls inside the target.
Once the dart hits the target,
you record the coordinates x
and y of the particular
point that resulted
from your dart throw.
And we record x and y with
infinite precision.
So x and y are real numbers.
So in this experiment, the
sample space is just the set
of x, y pairs that lie
between 0 and 1.